for you to be this much of a True
Believer what was the conversations like
at the kitchen table with Mom and Dad
what did you guys talk about I mean I
would go to family reunions and it was
like a soldier of fortune convention a
lot of the family had been you know
obviously in World War II Korea Vietnam
and a lot of them had been um you know
operatives in the CIA and things like
that but to me you're a kid and when the
family reunion's going on you know I'm
just uh you know getting on a
four-wheeler and you know taking a
shotgun off and shooting birds I'm not
you know hanging out with all these old
men and so my dad got into that for a
while he never told me what he did and
they decided like to get out of it and
just be a doctor at a certain point uh
but he the house was just full of all
this big new Brzezinski books and Henry
Kissinger stuff and just World politics
and you know just military manuals and
just stuff everywhere and so I just grew
up basically around all this stuff